Floria 60 Mundy's are turning doesn't
really have an ending it just stops
leaving viewers some puzzle over the
surreal images that close out the film
if you like everyone else were baffled
by the horror flicks bizarre ending
we're here to help it's hurting offers
two explanations for the spooky event
sublime Anna Eva Bligh is haunted by the
ghost of his late stable master quince
and Flora's former governess Miss Jessel
or Kate has gone completely crazy in a
sense the film azat both ways after Kate
receives a package full of paintings
from her mother who's mentally ill the
turning quickly devolves into a frantic
chase through a haunted house in this
version everything has a clear and
obvious answer Quint assaulted Miss
Jessel then killed her when she tried to
flee blind - caretaker mrs. Grose killed
Quint a few weeks later Quinta miss
Jessel spirits no horn the manor and
when the ghosts of Quinn turns violent
Kate loads the kids into the car and
flees simple right it's not that soon
here's a twist once Kate escapes play
the film cuts back to the scene in which
she's looking at a mother's painting it
tends differently this time instead of
running Kate confronts the children
clearly insane milestones Kate's and
then Kate as a vision of a mother
painting as mom lifts her head to Kate
Kate screams cue credits the way the
film is structured implies that the
second ending is the real one at the end
of the movie kate is insane it's not
clear if the first ending was a
prophetic vision or crazy person's
fantasy and we don't know if playas
actually haunted it doesn't matter
either way Kate has lost her mind so
what are we supposed to do with that
information the original text might hold
some clues the turning is actually an
adaptation of Henry James novella the
turn of the screw which was published in
1898 and there's been a popular ghost
story ever since with several film and
TV adaptations on the surface the
turning and the turn of the screw have
the same plot a younger woman moves to
an older stage where she's charged with
teaching an orphaned girl the girls Big
Brother arrives home and expectedly
after being expelled from his boarding
school
the governess begins to see the ghosts
of Quinn to miss Jessel and becomes
convinced other kids do too however in
the book the ending is very different in
the novella the kids are very clear
haunted by two ghosts flora is freed
from Miss Jessel spirits and escapes
however when the governess tries to make
miles explained why he was expelled
Quint appears the governess breaks
quince holder miles but the boy dies if
you take the text of face value then the
ghost supply manner are very real but as
you'll see that's a big if of course
while the turn of the screws ending
seems a lot clearer than the turnings
ambiguity is one of the stories oldest
traditions as early as 1907 one critic
suggested that the turn of the screws
ghosts unreal instead the argument goes
everything supernatural happens on the
governesses mine
she killed miles not some evil spirit
the blood is on her hands some people
agree others don't
defending the governess and insisting
that we're supposed to take the turn of
the screw at face value none of her me
James other ghost stories play fast and
loose with the narrative sanity and
nothing he said about the novella later
suggests that we shouldn't take the
governess that's a word it's a debate
that continues to this day although the
discussion kind of misses the point
James scared his audience that was his
real goal that Serling's weird and
confusing ending seems to be director
Floria 6a Mundy's attempt to capture
that same ambiguity no that doesn't
explain exactly what happened in the
conclusion of the film but at least it
explains where the filmmaker
decided to end things on such an odd
note there's a clue in the title perhaps
in the original novella the phrase turn
of the screw appears twice turning or
tightening a screw increases tension the
first time James user says he's talking
about how to make a scary story even
more frightening the second time the
governess is discussing how the
offensive line manner at testing her
sanity by calling the film that's
earning perhaps the filmmakers are
emphasizing that a story is really about
Kate's descent into madness and the
ghost question is secondary and eerily
ambiguous just like in the novella it's
also very hard to rule out the existence
of the ghosts entirely Kate starts
hearing voices almost as soon as she
moves into the manner before miles
starts playing psychological games with
her flora draws pictures of Miss Jessel
the mannequin modeled after miles and
Flora's ancestor moves its head after
Kate leaves the room we're not seeing
that through Kate's eyes so it seems
like it's real if it's not that's pretty
sloppy storytelling
maybe the turnings ghosts are real and
maybe there
in the end they don't matter like a
mother before her Cates goes crazy
that's the real horror in the story of
course that doesn't explain everything
that happens in the movie was the first
ending all in Kate's head or was there
more to it does Kate's mother have
prophetic abilities as a telling subtly
hints what exactly happened between miss
Jessel and quince and tell dick quince
mysterious accident occur that's earning
offers answers to some of these
questions but actively refuses to commit
to any of them is confusing and a little
off-putting
ultimately that Serling probably works
best as a story about a woman's descent
into madness aided by a sadistic child
and a bad draw at the genetic lottery
that's a ghost story it's pretty
run-of-the-mill
as a cinematic exercise in frustrating
mainstream horror audiences it succeeds
or wildly check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos buy your favorite horror movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]